yes so I title the talk a case for
oxidization clearly we're gonna be
talking about rust here and oxidization
is the process of by which we get rust
in case that wasn't clear yes so let's
let's get started here I want to start
with a personal story and then I'll
actually tell you what I'm gonna talk
about but I think it'll become clear
ordering it you already know what I'm
going to talk about but have become
clear while I'm gonna talk about it
through this personal story so about
five years ago I was at MIT doing my
masters and I was interested in
operating systems and all this kind of
thing and particularly I was interested
in using high-level languages to write
operating systems like could we write an
operating system in Python probably a
bad idea but could we do it could we do
it in Haskell what would that mean would
that be a good idea so I you know did
this thesis and the title of the thesis
was exploring OS development with
high-level languages that's sort of you
know it's what I just said the subtitle
of the thesis was but without a C
runtime so it was really important that
we're trying to get we're trying to use
these high-level languages presumably to
get security and correctness out of our
operating systems and then if we toss
see underneath all of it if C is the
thing that's really powering my Python
or whatever it is we're probably not
really doing much better than the status
quo so the fact that we know you C to
run a high-level language probably not a
good idea
so you know the gist of the research was
can we find programming language
primitives programming languages
programming language properties that we
can somehow convince ourselves lead us
to writing better operating systems so
the way I did this was to basically
write an operating system in all of
these languages so I wrote a tiny
operating system in every single one of
these languages I'm not gonna read him
out you probably know about most of them
you probably don't know all of them some
of these are research languages some of
these are esoteric languages including
Russ at the time but I went ahead and
just wrote an operating system in every
cent one of these languages just just to
see what it was like just to see if I
could maybe convince myself that there
was a point to doing this and that there
were good language properties that some
enabled us to write secure correct
operating systems and this was really
sort of a throw hundred darts at the
wall and then see what sticks kind of
thing there was no it wasn't like a
really great research process to this it
was like let's write about operating
systems so I did that and sort of a few
properties became clear about a few
properties became clear that we would
want to use for writing operating
systems and ideally we get correct
secure software out of it and sort of
the the implication of doing this was
that if it kind of worked out for
operating systems if I could find these
properties that worked for operating
systems then those properties would
probably make themselves amenable to
writing just general system software
file systems databases things of that
nature so I would ahead and did that and
I found a few properties that seemed
like really important to this kind of
work
particular we really wanted memory
safety the days in C and C++ are
numbered like we just don't want to seg
fault when our kernel is running ideally
because that means the entire machine
crashes we also wanted a very minimal
runtime again because if this runtime is
written in C and we're really not doing
any better and because we're lazy and
porting a runtime and to bare metal is
just not fun and we also wanted a nice
strong type system
ideally C we could encode properties as
part of the type as part of types in our
in our software and have a type system
sort of protect us from ourselves and
finally we are writing the operating
system we're writing a kernel we're
writing system software so clearly this
thing needs to be performant now I have
Haskell on the on the list here but
really should be like half a Haskell
because I started writing this operating
system and then it got to the point
where you know I was writing the thing
and I needed I needed it to run and that
meant porting the runtime which is about
50,000 lines of C code and I gave up
halfway through and nothing ever ran and
I was like ok I love Haskell but
definitely not an opportunist is not
definitely not for hiding operating
systems so this was the list and then
you know you kind of just buy jecht a
list with the properties of each of
these languages and you figure out sort
of what's gonna work so we do this table
here and you know you put some check
marks here and there and then we see hey
which languages have all the check marks
and for those of you that love a
particular language on this list and I'm
misrepresenting that language
I hear you I'm with you it's sort of
hard to just have checkmarks so bear
with me on the list here so if we look
at this you can see if there's two
languages that have all the check marks
in this case they are rust and cyclone
so at this point I'm sort of obligated
to tell you a little bit more about
cyclone so cyclone is this research
programming language created by very
smart people that gives you memory
safety without a garbage collector that
was sort of the main thing about the
language cyclone and sort of one of the
interesting things about cyclone is that
I was specifically it was specifically
designed to be a successor to see it was
not designed so it was a brand-new
language it wasn't like we can do these
crazy new things it was like hey we kind
of like C but the whole memory unsafety
thing we don't want that so what do we
do create a cyclone and in fact rust was
heavily inspired by cyclone and other
languages in that domain okay so we have
rust
we have cyclone there can only be one
winner so what do we do well you know
what I chose but you know I sort of took
it took a look at these languages I
wrote a few other operating systems in
these languages I've I wrote you know
more code I wrote some file system code
I wrote some virtual memory code I just
tried running more code to see if one of
these languages sort of emerged as the
winner at this point I should tell you a
bit about the history of rust at this
point rust was in version 0.5 or 0.6
this was 2013 and it was a very
different language than it is now if any
of you guys write rust it is not the
same language that being said I was
really impressed with the language
because not only did it have these four
properties that I was looking for it had
these additional properties it had it
allowed me to do to write high level
abstractions like functional looking
code that was pretty cool it allowed me
to do like memory allocators in this way
that I could convinced myself that they
were correct it also had a build system
that was a revelation that I could
actually write an operating system and
do like cargo build and then it would
build my operating system that was
insane I mean well you guys have written
C you've written to make file you you
know use Lib tool it's terrible did you
just we don't want that it was
incredible that I could write a little
Tamil file and cargo bill to my
would be built that was insane and not
only did it have these two things and
this third one really tripped me up I
was I was very confused by how this was
possible but it was data race free on
its web page it said rust if you write
your program in rust you cannot have
data races and I was I was you know I
didn't know what magician was creating
this language but I was really really
blown away
it's a clearly rust sort of won this
battle here and this talk is about
making a case for rust yeah clearly I
like I like rust rust is a is a fun it's
a good fun language so that's how my
sort of love affair with rust started
with operating systems and system
software in general so the way I want to
structure this talk is by first telling
you why we should care sir this was my
research and I cared sort of because I
had to graduate and because I just
generally cared the WYD should you care
well when we write software you know we
have bugs we write bugs because we are
human and it is hard to write good
software it is hard to write secure
software if you build a house you
probably want to use more than just you
know a hammer and nails you probably
want to use all the tools at your
disposal to make this house as nice as
possible and not only that but if you
know the people building the house could
tell you hey the roof it's never gonna
cave in for the next 65 years guaranteed
it's not gonna happen like that you'd
probably hire those people some of the
people who use hammer and nails so you
know I think we should build software
the same way let's use the right tools
let's get those guarantees let's you
know build this house nicely and you
know there's a lot of research that
tells us that C and C++ are very
ill-defined much more so that we sort of
thought and you know you can read
countless of research papers I tell you
this but you don't have to read research
papers to know that C and C++ are sort
of not what we should be doing you could
just read the tabloids and you can see
that Equifax lost you know six hundred
million dollars because they had a bug
in their program or because
yah-hoo lost 35 million dollars because
they had a bug in the program and
because all of these people's data was
just gone and cryptocurrencies just gone
and money is just gone and people's
infidelity is exposed and things of this
nature
so clearly you know there is a problem
and everything that I do this is
actually something I discovered recently
everything that I do is about creating
tools to help us prevent these kinds of
issues in some guaranteed fashion it's
cool if the toy helped but it helps us
it's cooler if the tool prevents us in a
guaranteed fashion from doing the wrong
thing and I genuinely believe that Rus
is in this class of tools it is a tool
that prevents us in a guaranteed way
from doing all of these wrong things and
I think it is exactly the kind of tool
that we should be using when it makes
sense now it's not the only kind of tool
there are other really great tools but
this is I think probably the best tool
we have at the moment especially for
writing system software ok so this is
how I'm going to structure the rest of
the talk that's sort of the introduction
here so first I'm going to tell you
about rusts guarantees and this is where
I'm gonna spend the majority of the talk
in particular I'm going to tell you
about how Rus guarantees memory safety
and race freedom it turns out I would
imagine that most people who write Rus
probably don't actually know how it
happens that's because it's sort of
weird and it doesn't totally make sense
unless you think about it for a long
time but I'm gonna tell you how it works
and then I'm gonna tell you how to use
rust to get more than just memory safety
and data race freedom and these things
that are just part of language and I'm
gonna do that through examples I'm gonna
show you
a web framework that I've been working
on called rocket and then I'm gonna tell
you about an operating system that I've
been working on called osmium and rocket
is kind of cool because it has compile
time security and safety guarantees for
the web things like if your web
application compiles you will not have a
CSRF attack you will not have a
cross-site scripting attack you will not
have a directory traversal attack I
think compiles these things are
guaranteed and osmium where you can
write device drivers and they will
automatically be verified for you I'm
talking about formal verification you
write your device driver in a certain
way press the button and it goes and
verifies it for you and then finally
because
rust is a scary language to learn I'm
going to tell you about how I taught
rust at Stanford and a brand new
operating systems class where undergrads
masters and PhD students wrote an
operating system in rust and hopefully I
can convince you that it's not too crazy
of a language learn okay so that's
that's what we're talking about let's
start with with rusts guarantees so rust
is a programming language being
developed
well the funding is the funding for
development is primarily by Mozilla
research but it's an open open source
project and as we sort of already
learned his memory safe without a
garbage collector you cannot have data
races he preparing compiles the runtime
is fairly non-existent it is smaller
than C++ is for instance you can do
functional programming you can have high
level abstractions you can have
structures and methods and all these
kind of nice stuff it has a really good
build system called cargo and it has
powerful macro systems that let you met
a program in kind of the way that you
want to and we're gonna look at each of
these things in sort of detail we're not
gonna talk too much about cargo but
everything else we're going to talk
quite a bit about so let's start with
memory safety so we're gonna talk about
memory safety we sort have to define
what memory safety is I think you all
probably have a you know some kind of
intrinsic belief about what - memory
safety is so I'm gonna go ahead and
define it precisely for you so memory
safety I'm going to define memory safety
as follows if you have a reference than
a dereference of that reference we're
gonna say it's always okay and if your
language has a property that a
dereference is always okay then we're
gonna say that this is a memory safe
language and by always okay I mean that
the dereference always succeeds as in
you don't seg fault you know just crash
and it always points to a value of a
correct type if you think you have a
struct it looks like this
and you dereference it then a pointer to
that thing you dereference then you have
a struct of that thing and the language
will guarantee that so that's our
definition of memory safety now this
definition is actually very strong it
has all these implications in particular
so one first of all it just is a direct
application
is if you have a reference then you do
often sit then you always get a foo if
you have a reference to foo need to
reference that reference you always get
a foo pretty easy well what does that
mean well that means that none of these
things have happened you don't have a
null pointer it points to a valid memory
address you don't have a dangling
pointer which implies you don't have
iterator validation you don't have use
after free you don't have double freeze
and there are no out of bounds accesses
you have a vector of size n you never
access anything outside those n elements
and this one is this one is this one is
weird this one's different you don't
have data races this is this is weird
because we have about every single
language that claims to be memory safe
does not prevent memory races and I
argue that none of those languages are
actually memory safe at least according
to my definition that includes things
like Java and go and yes
Haskell all of those languages are
mostly memories safe but they almost all
have this little escape hatch where if
you do things concurrently in a certain
way all of a sudden you'll get 2d
reference to a type and something else
will be in its position and so these are
these are our constraints for memory
safety so yes or no databases that's
that one's pretty important okay so
memory safety in rusts so how do we get
memory safety in rust so this is the
formula for memory safety it's
particular in rust so the first thing is
that rust will force you to initialize
everything you can never use something
until it's initialized it will also
restrict the way that you alias values
the pointers that you can create to
memory those can't a Leah sunder certain
conditions and finally it has this
concept of ownership that we'll talk
about later but the main idea between
behind ownership is that you cannot or
rather that the language always tracks
who is responsible for a given memory
address who's responsible for freeing it
who's responsible for allowing
references to be created that kind of
thing and if we sort of add these three
things together we get memory safety and
so I'm going to tell you how these
things sort of work ok and right so one
property here is that all this is
actually happening compile time so if
you guys are familiar with Java or go or
you know anything that has references
its garbage collected you can
still have no pointers and if you
dereference them then you'll get an
operator exception and that's within the
class of memory safety because if you
think about it sort of formally what's
happening is you dereference a thing and
then it crashes your program and so
that's okay because nothing executed
afterwards and so we're just gonna call
it memory safe but in rust this is a
compile time there is no such thing as a
run time check except for out of bounds
accesses because the type system isn't
expressive enough to sort of do the
right thing otherwise but in rust all
this stuff is happening at compile time
so how does this sort of magic work this
is pretty magical well let's talk about
aliasing let's talk about what goes
wrong when we have aliasing unrestricted
in the fashion of C++ so here's some C++
code if you're not familiar with C++
that's okay just you know follow along
with the pictures of the right here so
this is some code that is creating a
vector it's pushing a string to that
vector on line two it's getting a
reference to that string and it's
pushing a second string to that vector
and then it's printing out the string
that was referenced the first time
around and if you look at this closely
you'll spot a bug and this program will
more than likely seg faults so what's
going on here
so let's look at this line so on the
right here I have sort of a each square
is a memory location and each line is a
reference to that memory location so
when we do a V dot push back then the
vector V gets a reference to its
contents in this case it just has one V
zero in the next line and we create a
reference to that B zero and so now we
have X pointing to be zero in the next
line we push a new law a new string to
this vector and what's going to happen
is well we don't have enough memory to
hold this other string and so the vector
is going to have to deallocate the
current contents and then create you
know allocate more memory copy V zero
into that memory and then it has a spot
for V one but now this is a problem
because X is holding a reference to X
zero and so X is now a dangling pointer
and if we were to execute that next line
there then you know we would probably
ideally we'd seg fault in fact the
compiler is written so that it's seg
fault so you can catch it okay this is
sort of not good this is exactly the
type of thing we try and prevent with
rust so how do we
where's the problem here what's what's
going on well the problem is in this
line here the fact that we had these two
references these aliasing references to
the same memory location and then you
know something else came along and out
of all of a sudden change the reference
from underneath us that is a problem so
the problem is that aliasing is really
really hard and so how do we how do we
fix this how do we get rid of this
aliasing that we don't want
well one very easy way to do this is to
say no aliasing
you cannot alias anything there is just
a single reference to a thing and that's
it that you know what you have nothing
else there's actually a very popular
idea it sounds a little weird but it's a
popular idea known as a linear reference
to a linear type and the idea is that
you could choose either A or B you could
choose for V to reference b0 or you can
choose for X to reference to be 0 but
you can't choose both choose one and so
clearly we can't deallocate to V zero
while something is holding a reference
to it
because in order to deallocate it we're
gonna need a reference to it so this
would solve the problem but this is way
too restrictive I mean we're certainly
used to aliasing is you know okay except
when it's not so you want something in
the middle so you won't just don't just
want to get rid of references want to of
aliasing rather want to restrict
aliasing when they have some mechanism
by which the good aliases are allowed
and the bad aliases are denied by the
compiler so what what do we do well the
sort of insight here this is the sort of
main insight from rust and from
literature that rust borrows on is that
it's okay to have aliases as long as if
you have multiple aliases none of them
can mutate the thing being aliased and
so that means that you have in this case
you have three choices choice a is that
you can have an immutable aliases you
can't change the thing being alias
second choices you have exactly one
mutable alias and so in this case we
have two possibilities either V is going
to be lazing v-0 or or that should be xx
is aliasing mutability aliasing b0 but
that's it there's no other choices you
have any mutable aliases or one mutable
alias nothing else this is exactly what
rust will do rust will do exactly this
kind of restricted a leasing bus
ownership which turns out is important
and you'll see in just a second why okay
so let's take a look at how this
actually materializes in rust so here is
under ship and restricted aliasing in
rust so first part is we do have some
sort of leaner types in rust actually
and in particular we have this concept
of ownership and the idea is that
something actually owns the value it's
responsible for it and it can let go of
ownership but then it can never touch
that value again if you have a book and
you give it away books gone until
someone gives it back to you but you can
also lend someone the book and then they
can give the book back to you when
they're done but you are still the owner
and rust in fact encodes exact semantics
of ownership so this is what it looks
like this is some rust codes we have let
x equals some person and then you assign
X to Y well then you've given ownership
away of that person to Y and so you can
never touch X again and this would be a
compile-time error similarly if you pass
it to a function well now the function
owns the value and you know passing it
again to a function would be a
compile-time error you can also do this
with methods you have a method M that
takes self as a receiver then you cannot
call it twice because it gets moved into
the method but we still want a liasing
and if we want to get aliasing then we
have to borrow instead of give away and
so this looks like this so this is
something that's not allowed if you have
a person and then someone borrows a
person from you that's a strange concept
like soem borrows a person from you in
this case we use the ampersand to create
a pointer or borrows just the pointer
then we can't give it away because
someone else is borrowing at the times
you lend the book to your friend can't
possibly give it away to your other
friend the book is not in your hands
but you can borrow it again so this this
one does not fit the book analogy
clearly you don't have more than one
book to get out of your friends
I'm sure you can shoehorn the analogy if
you'd like I don't know you lend it to a
friend the other friend goes and reads
it from that friend something like that
but they can't scribble on it or
something so you can't have a mutable
reference to a thing and in a medial
reference to the thing so two immutable
references okay in a mutable reference
and in
reference not okay also you can't have
to me double references the rule here is
one mutable reference and no references
no other references or and immutable
references and the same thing happens
with methods so if you have a method
that takes a meet self then it will
immediately borrow it but the caveat
here is that once the method returns as
long as that borrow isn't stored
somewhere then you can borrow it again
it's like they gave it back to you so
you can call this method twice because
after the first call the borrow is
returned okay
so that's what's going on with rust this
is how it pans down in this example
here's a C++ code here's the rest code
again let's look at why this this code
won't compile and rust so here's a code
we'll start at the beginning we push
this string V now holds a reference to
it now X holds a reference to it and
they try to push this other string and
what rust will say is whoa in order to
push that string you have to be able to
mutate the vector but hey there's
currently a reference to that thing
inside the vector so clearly you
shouldn't be able to mutate the vector
and then it says sorry this breaks the
invariant of having either one exclusive
Beatle reference or only immutable
references so this code is not going to
compile now I sort of blindsided you a
bit there
because sort of X this this method this
push method calls push on V not on V
zero right so these are actually
distinct memory locations V and V zero
are distinct memory locations and push
will create a mutable reference to V
naught V zero so what's going on here
well this is where ownership sort of
plays a role here so what happens is
push comes along and it takes a mutable
reference to V and then through Rus
ownership semantics Rutz knows Oh V
actually owns V zero so if you are going
to be able to mutate V then you're going
to be able to mutate V zero and it will
implicitly create this you know solid
line - V zero and that's where the
aliasing constraint is actually broken
okay so this is exactly how rust does
it's magic there is a research paper
called rusty tights for solid safety
where I've actually formalized these
semantics and I've proven that this is
in fact memory safe so if you care to
read programming language literature
then look up
paper and you know enjoy the math okay
so we sort of skirted the idea of race
freedom but this should be somewhat
obvious at this point
well race freedom is defined you you are
race free if at most one rider exists to
a memory location at once like is a data
race is there is at least one rider and
some other reference to it both
accessing a memory location so clearly
if the language restricts you from
having more than one rider when anything
else exists then you will be race free
and that's true okay so you know if we
have these semantics then are we
database free well the answer is yes but
you know so is that it cool is that how
Russ does you know dating race freedom
well yes but it turns out that this kind
of sucks in general so let's say we have
this program here and we create a
mutable reference to zero and then in
two different threads we try to lock
that reference and then increment it and
then lock the same reference and then
increment it again this is totally race
free each thread has exclusive access to
this variable right and so you know
ideally the language would be like yeah
sure I can see that you're locking it I
can see that there's no way you can
actually access this mutable reference
at the same time in two different
threads but what the language actually
sees is that when you do this you know +
+ on a you need a mutable reference
because you can immune tape this thing
and clearly you're gonna have these two
mutable references in two threads and
Russ is gonna say nope sorry that's does
not does not hold so this breaks the
invariant you are not allowed to write
this code and in fact if you try to
write that code right now it would not
compile and so strangely enough
concurrency is impossible with safe rust
because of this restriction if we have
concurrency then we're going to be
writing from two different places at
once
ideally in a you know a race free way
but Russ cannot know this statically
these are dynamic guarantees and so
concurrency is rot in rust is not
actually possible with the language and
so concurrency actually has to be
provided by a
berries that use this concert called
unsafe to implement concurrency this is
it's an escape hatch to the language to
language of semantics that effectively
allow you to say hey rust I know what
I'm doing
now this is a bit of a misnomer because
unsafe code can't be wrong
unsafe code has to maintain every single
guarantee that the language itself will
maintain this is so yeah some people
don't like the word unsafe they should
you know people argue that we should
have used the word safe instead of
unsafe but there you have it so the idea
here is that libraries can't tell rust
hey I know what I'm doing and maintain
the invariants that it does statically
dynamically and this in particular for
concurrency you're going to do
particular kind of unsafety
called interior and readability and the
idea behind to your mean abilities
you're going to dynamically ensure
aliasing restrictions using this escape
hatch and what it's going to look like
is we're gonna have this function that
takes a shared reference an immutable
reference so you can have a bunch of
them and it's gonna give you a mutable
reference now you cannot write this
function in safe code but we can write
it with unsafe code here's sort of the
simplest way to write this interior
mutability thing here is a function and
don't you don't have to worry about most
of it but the part that's important here
is this atomic compare exchange thing so
what we're gonna do is dynamically check
that exactly one thing using hard the
hardware's idea of atomic operations
exactly one thing is going to be able to
get a mutable reference when this
function is called right so in this case
is actually much worse than we had it
before so if you look at this function
this says hey given a value you're gonna
be able to get one mutable reference for
the lifetime of the program and if you
ever try to do anything else we're gonna
crash there's actually way worse and
rust static guarantees but it
illustrates the idea that you have these
functions that give you shared
references and then give you a mutable
reference as a result and they can
maintain rusts alias and guarantees at
runtime instead of a compile time so
here's a better example of mutex this is
how the mutex is implemented in in the
sample library so in the lock function
we take a shared reference to mutex and
then we effectively do this in atomic
compare and exchange and while the thing
is locked while we cannot atomically
guarantee that we
are the sole owner of this thing then
we're going to spin and as soon as it's
ready we're gonna create this unsafe
cast two immutable reference now we sort
of want to know when this thing is ready
to be you know another beautiful
reference is ready to be created and so
in the destructor for the for the mutex
we're going to do exactly that we're
going to set it from being locked to
being unlocked and now okay let's go
back and so now what's gonna happen is
we create this lock thing and then you
can use it as however you want as soon
as it gets destructed and we know that
it's a unique destruction because of
rusts ownership rules then we're gonna
free the lock and everything is nice and
dandy and so this is how you regain
concurrency and rust even though the
language itself prohibits it and so now
we can actually write code that looks
like this or you create a mutex is
invariable we lock it plus plus we lock
it plus plus and we're good to go you
actually see if there's actually nicer
than the code we were up before is nice
in the code read right in you know see
so it's pretty cool but yes you cannot
do concurrency in safe rust pretty
pretty weird thing okay so that's uh
that's all I want to say about russ
guarantees now the next parts of the
talk are much smaller than the first
part here so the next thing I want to
talk about is doing more than just
memory safety and I'm gonna talk to you
about rocket this web framework and
about osmium this operating system
so here's rocky at this is rockets logo
I like it so I put it up so rocket is a
web framework for us that makes it
simple to write secure correct web
applications without sacrificing
flexibility or type safety secure
correct flexible and performant this
quad vechta of things that's what we're
looking for you and so just to be clear
when I say web framework I mean you know
like a Django or like a spring or like a
rail is that kind of thing so rocket is
somewhat it's been around for a little
bit
twenty sixteen wasn't there's released
released zero points who after that sort
of point three after that and there's an
emoji font missing on the machine
running this but that's a little star
it's a github star there's got like
forty five hundred give github stars
people like it we've got tens of
thousands of users we have some people
using it in production NPM is actually
running services
in rocketing production assistance 76
laptop makers are running stuff in
production
Mozilla I don't know what they're doing
but they have a bunch of things written
in rocket and if they're deploying them
or not
but people are using this thing so
that's cool and so when I say secure
particular I want to I want to be very
clear about what I mean
and that's and that's that we have all
these problems with the web and we don't
want these problems and rocket fixes the
problems ideally and I separate these
into three categories this green lists
are the things that are you know if you
don't know web stuff that's okay this
green thing I say we have pretty good
ideas about how to solve them this
yellow thing least yellow stuff we have
solutions but they're not guaranteed
solutions nothing stops you from
circumventing them easily or just
accidentally and then these couple of
other things have no good solutions to
them you write a rails app you can miss
configure it all day and nothing's going
to tell you that you've done the wrong
thing and so what rock is gonna do is
for these green things here it's just
gonna use the existing solutions except
it's gonna guarantee them if your thing
compiles you cannot have these issues
these middle things we're gonna have new
solutions and again they're gonna be
guaranteed and the red stuff here we
have brand new solutions and again we
can't guarantee them but we're gonna try
really really hard to steer you in the
right direction so you don't get it
wrong and ideally if we do a good job
everything turns green and we can go
home and write web apps all day and not
worry about what's going on okay so this
is what rocket looks like I'm not gonna
spend too much time you know telling you
what's going on but a few things that I
want to emphasize first I think this
looks it's it's pretty cool this looks
this way and this is like a C successor
this looks I mean I think it looks kinda
like Python I mean there's also question
marks and I mean exclamation marks in
there and stuff but ignore the
exclamation marks or the question
whatever ignore other weirdness and
focus on the coolness that's that's how
I sell things nor the weirdness focus on
the stuff you like I also feel like
that's how relationships work just focus
on the things you like and you'll be
happier all right enough of life advice
okay see what's going on here the first
part is this top thing where you
effectively specify how requests are
gonna match this thing so in this case
we're a match get requests to things
that have an ID
and then the second thing here we're
gonna validate each of those things
using a type we're gonna specify a type
for each of these things and so we're
gonna say ID is gonna be a paste ID now
there's this other thing here user that
is not like present in the attribute and
what this is called it's a request guard
it's a way for you to give rocket an
arbitrary type and say hey this is how I
validate a request that is supposed to
contain something that in this case is a
user and so you might imagine that the
functionality for validating requests to
have a user is looking at cookies you go
check the database you check expirations
and whatnot nan says and then you say
yep here's a user and then finally you
write the code to do the work and you
output some type in this case this is
like a paceman example so you're
retrieving a paste bin for some user and
you're gonna return maybe a file the
file was there and maybe not the file
wasn't there but the neat thing is here
you write only the code that is gonna
sort of act on the good stuff
everything is validated before the code
runs and here's one interesting case of
sort of using this functionality here is
a static file server written in rocket
it is exactly 49 for lines and is
guaranteed to not be vulnerable to
directory traversal attacks directorate
traversal attackers when someone gives
you a path and because of the string
that they gave you all of a sudden you
give them whatever file they want and
clearly that's not good because we have
sensitive files on our machine and the
implication here is that as I just said
handlers are only called in validated
data and there's some magic going on
here with type classes and traits and
whatnot but the gist of it is that this
path buff type does this validation and
if you get a type of path buff in your
handler then you are guaranteed to be
able to use this type to open files and
do whatever you want okay so that's
that's rocket is the website rocket dot
RS I know you're looking at me I see you
yeah I'll be done very soon I assure you
this is a web site you go there and
check it out all right I'm gonna breeze
through the rest of this this is osmium
it's an operating system here is what it
does you write device drivers in osmium
you encode a state machine in rust and
it looks like this and then the second
thing you do is you write these little
implementations that effectively allow
you to query the device for what state
it thinks it's in and then you connect
Sheen to something we call a monitor
just another machine and that's
literally it
you do these things too right you drive
in a certain way you write these little
methods that effectively look at unit
tests you connect the machine to another
one and then you press play and it will
verify the device however for you and
the gist of it is that because rust is
so structured because of ownership types
then you can you can directly encode the
state machine in rust we can read the
state machine off from the types we can
run the state machine we can generate
code that runs the state machine and
checks it against the device's state
machine and see if they're equivalent
and if everything says yes then
everything works out all right that's
awesome
last thing two minutes teaching crust I
think is actually pretty important that
I get to this part because for those of
you that haven't learned rust
my guess is one of the big reasons is
because you're like this is a scary
language and it is kind of a scary
language and so I taught this class at
Stanford called CS one for TE a brand
new class that I designed and taught at
Stanford for the first time and this was
the deal with the class the students
were gonna learn OS fundamentals they
were gonna write an operating system
they're gonna build an OS from scratch
in rust for the Raspberry Pi 3 they're
gonna learn embedded development
fundamentals and they're gonna write
drivers and all neat stuff a bit about
the cohort for the class I asked them
have you implemented any bare metal
software such as boot loaders advise
drivers and what is that 71% said no and
then I asked them hey what do you write
software in and they said C C++ Java
Python JavaScript and you know one or
two people said other things but zero
people said they had written rust
so there were about 25 students in class
and none of them had written rust here
are the key takeaways
so first the students were comfortable
with rust in about four weeks and about
comfortable about four weeks give or
take comfortable give or take a week or
two every single student wrote an OS
successfully in ten weeks and the OS did
interesting things it had a memory
allocator had a file system it had
device drivers and I essentially
handling it processes in context which
think this is a real wes for 64-bit arm
and a multi-core platform and not a
single student use gdb this is insane
because in the original version of this
class yes 140 gdb was taught
you spend a week teaching gdb to
students because they will segfault and
crash so much not a single student use
gdb so I think if you want to check it
out sis 140 does Stanford 80 do I think
this is a good a good example of you
know that rust is teachable and
learnable okay so that's all I have to
say I'm Way over time thank you for
letting me be over time this is what we
talked about this is me this is my email
address you guys have any questions on
any of this stuff I'm more than happy to
talk about it I have a workshop as well
on rocket if you want to learn more
about how rocket does what it does
please come to the workshop thank you so
much for your time
[Applause]